- Painting this galaxy
on my nails, I think,
is probably harder than actually
flying into outer space.
(upbeat music)
I'm just gonna go for it, I'm just gonna
put the polish on the sponge.
They did it really neatly,
I don't see that happening.
It's just blobs.
It'll get there.
It's actually really pretty.
Never give up on yourself.
I'm gonna start Pinteresting.
I really think that this pink is gonna,
like, make this entire thing pop.
Aww man, that was so disappointing.
Every time I put on a layer,
it covered up the last layer.
How am I gonna do my right hand?
I think they were prettier without it,
I shouldn't have done it.
Look how beautiful it
looks without the stars.
And look how dumb it
looks with these stars.
- I have absolutely no confidence
in myself being able to do this.
This is gonna be bad.
Now I think I put the different colors
of the ombre on the sponge.
I have my stripes.
This is gonna go terribly, I can tell.
Oh my god, this looks so, so bad.
I've never been good at Pinterest.
Take two.
Oh, look at that!
(laughs)
It's not ugly.
It's also not what I was going for.
- I'm an art major, so I feel like
I should be able to do this.
It already doesn't look like the picture.
Here we go.
Woah!
It's not quite like the picture,
but some good stuff was happening.
Going in for, now, number 2.
Oh no.
Something went wrong.
This isn't good, guys.
I am going to have to
clean up a whole lot.
I have a lot of respect
for the people on Pinterest
who can do this, because I
can't, and I'm an art major.
- I don't think it's gonna be easy,
I think it's gonna be
really time consuming,
But ultimately, worth it.
My fear is like, I put the tape on,
and then I rip it off and then
I have no nail polish underneath.
Putting on the tape is actually
way crazier than I thought.
I'm gonna have to like, measure this.
This is like surgery.
This is like, who has time for this?
The other hand is gonna
be a complete disaster,
I can already tell you right now.
Oh, I totally skipped a finger.
I totally forgot about my finger.
You know what, I probably would've
been better at freestyling this.
Tape is so hard.
Oh my god, and I have to
cut it with my left hand.
How long has it been?
I can't remember a time before this.
Okay, not too bad!
Okay, this hand is done.
This is pretty cool.
There's something there.
I would say you need a good 3 hours.
- This is that thing you do now,
like when your nails
are wet, and you like,
you don't wanna, like, touch
anything, or grab anything.
Yep, I already (bleep) this one up.
I don't know how they fit
so many dots on one nail.
And that nail is shorter than mine.
I will say, this is very relaxing.
Okay, I'm gonna try to
get like, a thin line.
Looks like those paintings
people think are vaginas.
I bet if we did a video like this of like,
doing your nails while you're drunk,
it would still look exactly like this.
Remember when I said this was relaxing?
Now I'm finding it tedious.
The green helps a lot, to like, be like,
hey look, this is a flower.
I would do this again.
I might just do, like, an
accent nail on each hand.
Because I think this
is also kind of a lot.
- [Voiceover] I think no one looks good
when they paint their own nails.
We all look like we just learned
that we had opposable
thumbs, or something.
And like, just figuring
them out for the first time.